graphiste architectes naturopathe ou
encore avocate
au total 53 exposants étaient présentes
samedi à l'hôtel de ville de versailles
pour le premier salon talents de femmes
parmi elles corinne elle se lance dans
la création de couronnes de l'avent
l'idée c'est que pendant des années ma
fille née à 21 ans j'ai quatre enfants
et je leur fais des couronnes de l'avent
depuis qu'ils sont tout petits
et du coup d'année en année je me suis
rendu compte que mes copines et surtout
les enfants de mes copines on avait eu
même très envie et que du coup bah
c'était sympa d'apprendre à les faire il
était effectivement tant que je pense à
moi et que je redevienne une femme pas
qu'une mère et que du coup bas j'arrive
maintenant je vais essayer d'allier les
deux mettre en valeur ces femmes des
yvelines qui concilie vie
professionnelle et vie personnelle
le but de ce salon organisé par le club
soroptimist de versailles une ong qui
intervient pour la défense et
l'entreprenariat féminin
aujourd'hui on est très fiers de pouvoir
dire qui avec les élus des veline donc
avec notre cher maire françois mazières
qui nous a obtenu de donner la
possibilité de créer le premier salon
talents des femmes dans la région des
yvelines on met un avant tout les
talents des les femmes dans
l'entrepreneuriat dans tous les métiers
toutes les exposants du salon la même
motivation revaloriser la place de la
femme dans la sphère professionnelle
je pense que la femme est aussi un
acteur aujourd'hui important parce que
la diversité à mon sens est une vraie
synergie dans une entreprise
et on a besoin également de ce dynamisme
féminin tous les fonds récoltés à ce
salon seront reversés le 12 octobre à
l'association vivre ensemble au château
de versailles lors d'une dictée géante
avec plus de 1000 enfants d'île de
france